now we begin with a disturbing story out
of New York City where police officers
were beaten by a violent mob that police
say was made up of migrants this
horrifying video shows the moment that
the attackers pounded two NYPD officers
police say those officers were trying to
break up a disorderly crowd outside a
shelter in Times Square but when they
tried to arrest one of the individuals
the mob attacked pushing and punching
the officers
you can even see one suspect here
kicking an officer in the face while he
is on the ground one officer suffered a
cut to his face while the other
sustained body bruises five of those
violent suspects were arrested by police
later that same night they faced charges
for assaulting a police officer and more
with police sources telling Fox that one
of the men arrested has two open Assault
and robbery
charges but to add insult to injury
according to court records at least four
have been released without bail the NYPD
chief of Patrol spoke out this morning
you saw the video
reprehensible
cowards you have eight
people attacking on a lieutenant and a
cop running up to them trying to kick
him in the face and kick him in their
face the four that are arrested should
be sitting in Rikers right now on
bail should be indicted this week and
taken off our
streets you want to know why our cops
are getting
assaulted there's no consequences and we
must change this end of
story Jimmy F you come from a strong
family history with with a lot of police
officers in your family and earlier the
police benel event Association Patrick
said uh president Patrick Henry
condemned the attacks and the criminal
justice system he said there is an
epidemic right now of assaults on police
officers and the reason he said are open
door revolving door cases like this one
100% we've broken the compass in society
in that we have a criminal justice
system now that has more empathy for the
criminal than the victim certainly more
of empathy for the criminal than the cop
and I think that's emblematic of the
aftermath of the summer of 2020 but
there's a reality that at the tippy top
of all of these state governments and
certainly the federal government as a
whole there's a basic indifference to
this quality of life decline that
witnessing everywhere I travel a lot as
a comic I go to every town you can think
of cuz I don't have the best agent okay
but the point is no I kid I've seen it
everywhere I go you pull off the exit
ramp and you're like wow this town seems
to have let itself go but it's not the
town people that feel that way it's the
fact that they can't get the laws
enforced and when it comes to the border
that border crisis as we know is now a
dereliction of Duty that affects every
state in the country so I'm not
surprised by this but I'm frankly
disgusted that we've had this many of
these and it still hasn't been addressed
and stopped and Harris you know what
Jimmy's talking about is real but I
argue that that that numbness you know
the apathy that's not on the part of of
the citizens that's 100% in those in
those positions of decision making
because they're the ones that for some
reason aren't seeing it this guy I
mentioned that that has the the um
pre-existing cases he was arrested for
punching biting and kicking a retail
employee he tried to steal from them he
punched a loss prevention
officer so I am shocked by this cuz I
didn't realize we' migrated so far as a
society that we would give criminals who
potentially have come across the border
illegally the same rights that our
people have which have been mitigated so
much by softon crime policies like I
mean it's gotten so so much easier for
the criminals and so much harder for the
victims and now the people who break our
number one law first coming across the
border number one thing like you didn't
even get here legally and then they get
to do more crime against us and then you
let them go per the things that are on
the books for the criminals who are
American zero bail so I'm I'm I am
actually surprised and shocked that we
have gotten that far but I don't want to
be surprised or shocked about what has
to happen next I want to feel confident
that we're going to do the right thing
and that is if we think these guys came
over illegally Deport them now do not
spend another dime of taxpayer money
trying to figure out what they did and
what they didn't do they were already
criminals if they if they did do this
send them back if they didn't do this
send them back no more taxpayer money
trying to Harbor and normalize crime by
criminals who don't respect this country
enough to try to get in line and come
here legally full stop and and just one
thing to add and I'm sorry okay what
frustrates me is this is not a political
issue okay crime affects all of us when
you get mugged they don't ask who you
voted for and this is a moment where you
realize the point you just made is not a
conservative point it's an American
Point America is better than it's a true
point we have sovereignty as a nation I
don't care how you vote I don't care
what what you think what I know is this
is the United States of America and if
they broke laws to get here don't spend
another dime on them Deport them and it
seems Kaylee that in that equation that
faulty equation it's the police officers
it's the kids that are getting the worst
end of the deal we've talked about this
at length kids are getting shoved off
their soccer fields and now we are
watching NYPD get assaulted and that's
supposed to be okay we know last year's
numbers here alone reached 100,000
illegal immigrants we know that we are
projected to spend 12 billion doll as a
city in the next 3 years and we watch
our cops getting beaten down while they
are continued subjected to horrible
regulations and laws and policies that
are demoralizing and underfunding when's
enough enough enough is enough so these
men who are purportedly We Believe here
illegally that's at least the fact
pattern we have currently the charges
assault of a police officer gang assault
obstructing governmental Administration
disorderly conduct you mention the
individual who already has a separate
assault charge and in that incident he
allegedly pushed punched and bit someone
yeah bite biting was occurred and
punched a loss prevention officer which
is what you mentioned but what I'm
interested in you know that's all state
law here in New York we'll see if they
get convicted they will have their day
in court but we have federal law the
immigration and nationality act which
says and I'm going to quote it directly
the Attorney General his name is Merrick
Garland by the way currently the
Attorney General shall take into custody
certain migrants here they are among the
classes of migrants he shall take into
custody someone who's inadmissible on
specified criminal grounds they're
deportable by reason of having committed
a specified criminal offense among the
specified criminal offenses AGG
aggravated assault so I would love to
see the interaction of state law here
should there be a conviction federal law
and we have to wait to see if there's a
conviction but if there is will the
Attorney General take action is this a
specified criminal ground it should be
if it is not already and to your point
the kids remember the brilliant idea of
we're going to put these guys in school
gyms next to kids in school these guys
attacking a police officer potentially
by New York City school children
brilliant
idea and the age of these men too these
young men 19 years old 20 21 we also
have reported on a host that have come
through with zero ID remember photos are
elective at the airport who are claiming
to be minor so they get the protection
as well of this amnesty light that this
Administration likes to subject
Americans to which only render us more
dangerous and these kind of crimes that
we watch on live TV that's right Emily
and you know as an immigrant myself that
spent 10 years becoming a citizen I see
this and the easeness of just walking
across skipping the line we talk about
follow the process right now there is
over 1.4 million work visas that are
backlog those are folks with phds with
mbas graduates from American
universities that are getting de
prioritized because of the crisis but
here's one thing that nobody's talking
about this video we keep playing over
and over again is the best advertisement
today tomorrow this coming month for the
smuggling networks that are making more
than 13 billion doar a year with the
business of crossing over people freely
and that is no longer just freelancer
coyotes here and there it's a network to
the cartels that puts our national
security at risk and it's just we need
to understand that allowing this is
perpetuating the advertisement of come
to America so easy and you go there and
you don't get in trouble yeah you get
treated just like an America citizen who
commits a crime even have sex change
surgery in California that's right
although I love your word however all of
us have been deprioritized and that is
Biden's America hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-host Harris
and Kaye mchan on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights